hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Beowulf episode 3 Baio just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet really the big stuff this week
was wrapping up that Skinshifter plot
one of my favorite moments was when he
was screaming at them I come from an
ancient people I'm sure there's no way
all that mythology isn't going to come
back and bite all these people in the
ass most of the people in positions of
authority including Beowulf to a certain
degree aren't really paying too much
mine to the business that's going on
beyond this council vote like you have
all these villages that existed in the
semi true state and everyone's just
worried about each other instead of all
these external forces that we haven't
really seen yet they mentioned the
warring we kind of get a teaser for them
during slean's storyline and it was
really sad to see David Harewood go out
but he has bigger things to do on
Supergirl
no no spoilers for that just careful for
spoilers because he plays a really big
comic-book character and some of you
might not have seen it yet but I guess
we can kind of organize this by
storyline so starting with the
Skinshifter we learned that someone was
using him as their glorified finger
puppet turns out it's liens uncle Rita's
brother so what's going to be happening
now now that Slean found out that he was
also behind the kidnapping so his uncle
along with wolf Ling are like the
biggest villains of the group right now
wolf laying tried to rape Rita so of
course he's a complete dirtbag but he's
more of a piece of human trash than he
is a master planner slean's uncle is the
one that's trying to be the emperor
behind Darth Vader he's trying to
destabilize erat so he can take control
of the council and he promises Slean I
will have the power to make you faint
someday which I know is what you want
and even though he's kind of a dirtbag I
feel like he just has a more complex
hero arc so by the end of the series he
will be a little bit more positive
but he's still something of an
opportunist so he doesn't turn his uncle
in he's trying to use it to his
advantage yes of course that's gonna
bite him in the ass but I'm interested
to see between Rita and slain who is
going to take their uncle down I don't
think he's going anywhere anytime soon
he's a really powerful person in his own
right
he's thane of his own village where rita
comes from so what he might do is just
try to create an alliance with wolf ling
or the other leaders of the council that
hate rita favorite performance in the
episode though was David Harewood as
expected just you know amazing actors so
it's sad to see him come and go so
quickly but I feel like it was also a
good term for Beowulf and slean's
character well they they kind of
dismissed it at the end they had that
moment where it was like oh thank you
for coming to save me
well I didn't come just for you if
there's any tension between the two of
them it's really coming from slean's end
he just really has this inferiority
complex where you think the Beowulf is
this amazing warrior that their father
loved more I don't think that he knows
that Beowulf is secretly his father's
biological son that would probably make
things pretty bad between them but I'm
hoping to see them grow closer before
they reveal that and then someone can
use that information to pull the rug out
from under them like Slean will just go
back to hating Beowulf it's always a
little more interesting when there's
that kind of conflict between two
characters eventually I kind of think
they're gonna have the Captain America
Bucky type relationship where yeah like
they'll fight each other but they'll
wind up being friends watching this
Simpsons level mob go after the
Skinshifter and his family was pretty
heartbreaking they're actually ready to
throw themselves under the bus and it
sounds like slean's uncle would have
killed his family if the Skinshifter had
come clean so that's probably why he
didn't say anything even though everyone
kind of figured out yes someone else is
making him do this things are only gonna
get worse between all these villages I
know they're building towards the
council vote and they'll resolve that
plotline relatively soon but that's not
going to be the end of the infighting
and you have to remember that there are
also other external forces the warig are
a huge group of people very dangerous
very feral that they need a lot of
warriors to fight and most of those
forces come from this village here
Bharath itself does not have the
manpower to sustain an ongoing battle
with everyone else and the war at the
same time so slean's uncle is able to
turn a couple of the other villages to
his cost and go against Rita and then
the warring chargin things are gonna go
wild it's gonna be a lot of fun but it's
gonna be crazy so I'll be really
interested to see how quickly everything
blows up in everyone's faces let me know
in the comments though what was your
favorite moment from episode 3 and what
do you think is gonna end up happening
between Celina and his uncle if
someone's gonna end up killing him do
you think it'd be slain or do you think
that Rita would do it herself like she
killed her brother or Slean would kill
his uncle episode 4 is gonna air next
Saturday February 13th on the Esquire
network it's at 10/9 central
and if you want more behind the scenes
stuff from the show you can go to their
website it's Esquire tv.com slash
Beowulf they have a bunch of cool
behind-the-scenes stuff and interviews
with the actors episode 4 is really
where it starts to get crazy they tease
some more mythology that's gonna be spun
out through episodes 5 & 6 so be sure to
check it out episodes 4 5 & 6 are gonna
be really crazy so while you guys wait
for my next video to
in case you haven't seen it you can
click here for my episode 2 video and
you can click here for my episode 1
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight